look at the [ __ ] one with the body
get out of here no too many flavors
one for the winner did he steal all
these the way you end with my like ass
in but well that's [ __ ] honestly
that's 18 grand right there on this one
he's about to get fired from macy's is
that a neiman marcus like you know that
little counter yeah that's a fire hazard
right there and that that is
what's the question he said king are
stinging at more than one cologne
you want one set man so when people
smell you're like that's bishop no no no
no no dude what the [ __ ] are you saying
what are you doing i like how outraged
he is
when somebody walks into a room and you
just [ __ ] and they're all inside yeah
yeah yeah bro you're just talking about
being inside you know
in my mind the smell that's horrible bro
you know the same thing when you get in
an uber and the guy's [ __ ] squirting
it all up and it's [ __ ] awkward to
georgia well he's screaming and he's
just so he's [ __ ] driving go get up
oh oh what bro oh you smell better
looking then you're not tricking anyone
well that guy's
spraying that [ __ ] because he probably
farted or he's covering marijuana i'm
just talking about little sprays what
you're saying
okay but how do you how do you put on
cologne where do you put it i put on my
neck and then i go under the shirt bro
how about how that's a lie though i want
to pick up the pheromones man i want to
smell the real brendan shop i want to
smell the real oh you want that you want
this
dude dude
sweet nectar but yeah i'm a sweet nectar
but if you want this guys no i
understand but if you're with like a
chick and she's smelling like a
department store and you're like oh nice
and then the department store wears off
and you [ __ ] smell a little bit of
sandwich on her that's gross as [ __ ] man
you don't want sandwich-smelling girls
smelling like a department store
tricking the [ __ ] out of you i'm not the
real [ __ ] because that's how it's gonna
last bro it's a lie man unless they
sting it's a lie but here's the other
thing though dude
women like what men they don't like a
[ __ ] guy smelling like i could do
giorgio well i disagree no no because
well that's what makes you wrong
somebody has to be wrong here dude but
what i'm telling you is
what i'm telling you is you don't wear
it let's get down let's boil it down to
the brass tacks dude
there is no cologne there is only
perfume so if you're a man and you get
cologne and you squirt it on you yeah
congratulations you're a woman
and that's okay it's 2022. you don't
wear anything where's your [ __ ] brendan
[Laughter]
yeah
you know what i can't do it bro you go
oh
yeah daddy
i like that you own it but don't do that
man
just like on the island i think he
swayed eric exactly bro this is an
island boy no i was already on this
on this train this is highlighted
i i sometimes because i have like but my
thing is just like did i take a little
dab oh
because when i'm doing the meet and
greets and somebody goes you smell good
yeah
give it to me
i'm with them man it's not to bring them
in it's to keep them close the number
one combo dang you smell good and i have
no idea what it is yeah it's a silver
bottle wow it looks insane but i don't
like too much i i i wouldn't do it i
don't want to smell like an armenian you
know what i'm saying i don't want to i
want to be drenched in armenians like
that's not enough bro you need more
squirts bro you don't put it in your
mouth like that
okay i don't know what accent that is
that's armenian bro did you go down to
glendale man they squirted in their
mouth
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh you like you
think oh my god that's where armenians
were when you grew up in la canada all
right there was no
mexicans or armenians
let me know if i can shut up
armenian central bro it's armin et
cetera in la canada hey bro
i love the movie scarface that's what
they would all say all the time
[Laughter]
they look because it's a latin reference
yeah but that's what they because well
bro i mean we're gonna get really racist
in a second but all i'm saying is
armenians love the movie scarface
first you get the money then you get the
power then comes the respect no the
[ __ ] but that's what
dude
just [ __ ] colonist perfume
[Music]
is
[Music]